jean-luc Picard is back for a new
adventure in Star Trek Picard
once again boldly going where no one has
gone before
the CBS all access show is filled with
callbacks to Star Trek past including
some that might allude even the most
dedicated of fans the first episode of
Star Trek Picard opens to the music of
Irving Berlin as Bing Crosby croons the
lyrics to blue skies it's a curious song
choice for a show set in the distant
future but the nearly century-old song
holds a surprising amount of
significance for jean-luc Picard early
on in Star Trek nemesis the final film
in the next-generation movie series
Lieutenant Commander data channels the
classic crooners of the past by
performing blue skies at the wedding of
Will Riker and Deanna Troi toward the
end of the film before data is destroyed
sacrificing himself along with the
riemann ship
scimitar data attempts to transfer his
memories to be for an earlier prototype
of the Android made by his creator dr.
Noonien Soong unfortunately before is
not nearly as advanced as data and it
appears the transfer was a failure until
before begins softly singing blue skies
to himself at the end of the movie the
cards reaction in nemesis indicates that
he suspects there may be some of data
still alive after all a thread that is
carried forward into the first episode
of Picard in which the former captain
not only visits with data and his dreams
but speculates that the essence of data
now lives on in a new form since the
next generation ended with a poker game
it's only fitting that Picard should
begin with one the first episode sees
John Luke and data playing cards aboard
the enterprise engaged in the same sort
of conversation we've seen them
participate in countless times before
analyzing yet another of datas attempts
to appear more human
this time Picard is sizing up data's
humanity in the form of a poker tell
data is dilating one pupil in order to
fool the captain into believing he has a
good hand while Picard deduces that his
real tell is when he does nothing at all
the scene helps viewers feel immediately
at home in the new show bringing back
settings themes and characters that have
already been familiar for decades
but it also calls back to the final
episode of
next generation all good things after
skipping through time and saving all
life in the universe
the final scene finds the crew of the
enterprise engaged in their regular
poker game they're surprised when Picard
arrives and asked to join but welcome
him to the table and the series ends
with the captain dealing the cards while
saying the sky's the limit in Picard the
poker game makes it clear that we're
picking up where the previous show left
off and setting it the blue skies could
even be calling back to Picard's final
line a poker game also opens the next
generation episode the measure of a man
in which data's Humanity is put on trial
in that episode data also uses poker as
an analogy to try to illustrate the
difference between knowledge and
memories the themes of that episode feel
relevant to Picard a sad future in which
synthetics like data have been deemed
too dangerous to exist and have been
outlawed entirely when jean-luc is
getting ready for his interview
evaluating his appearance in the mirror
we get a brief glimpse of a
cream-colored fedora with a black band
hanging on a coat rack behind him from
the perspective of the camera the Hat
almost appears to be sitting on Picard's
head at a jaunty angle what at first
glance could be mistaken for just a
random piece of set-dressing actually
harkens back to one of Picard's favorite
holodeck characters the 20th century
detective Dixon Hill the gumshoe was one
of young Jean Luc's childhood heroes and
Picard dawn the Private Investigators
characteristic trench coat and fedora on
numerous occasions during the next
generations run most notably during the
season 1 episode the big goodbye in that
episode the simulated mystery Picard is
trying to solve on the holodeck involves
the death of a young woman foreshadowing
the real-life puzzle he finds himself
caught up in as Picard begins during
Picard's fateful interview about the
Romulan supernova and his retirement
from Starfleet the interviewer mentions
that the Utopia Planitia shipyards on
Mars were completely destroyed in the
synthetic attacks during the supernova
it's a passing comment in a laundry list
of the catastrophic events that brought
Picard and the Federation to they're now
opposing positions but Utopia Planitia
isn't just some random futuristic words
thrown in for emphasis the shipyard has
a lot of significance in Star Trek lore
the Utopia Planitia shipyard served as
one of the primary Starfleet ship
construction sites across several Star
Trek series among the many ships that
were constructed there were the USS
Voyager the USS Defiant which featured
prominently in Star Trek Deep Space Nine
and of course the flagship herself the
USS Enterprise 1701 D further commander
Benjamin Sisko served for several years
at Utopia Planitia before taking command
of the Deep Space nine space station I
would have thought that after three
years spent at the Utopia Planitia yards
that you will be ready for a change
jean-luc has several dreams of data
during the first episode of Star Trek
Picard but one of the most pivotal
moments occurs when he dreams of data
painting a woman in white robes gazing
over a turbulent sea this dream accused
Picard to go find a painting the real
data gifted to him 30 years earlier
which depicts the same young woman who
showed up in Picard's vineyard earlier
in the episode while data explored a lot
of artistic pursuits over the course of
the next generation his painting and
Picard seems to call back specifically
to the sixth season episode birthright
part 1 in which data experiences a
confusing vision and asked Captain
Picard how he should go about
interpreting it Picard
urges him to explore what he saw in a
way that feels meaningful to him and
data decides to use painting to explore
the images in his head ultimately after
painting dozens of pictures data
determines that he has accessed a new
level of his programming and can now
dream which he resolves to continue
doing henceforth it seems only fitting
that data's painting pursuits would come
full circle in Picard with jean-luc
using the image of data painting in his
dreams to find meaning in what's
happening in his real life even in death
it seems his old Lieutenant Commander is
still able to help him out
when Picard goes to visit his vault in
the Starfleet archives we get a brief
glimpse of two prominently displayed
model ships neither of which is the
enterprise
the first is the USS stargazer the first
starship Picard ever commanded this was
the ship on which he would first perform
the battle tactic that eventually came
to be called the Picard maneuver using a
brief burst from the ship's warp drive
to confuse the sensors of the opposing
ship making it appear as though the
stargazer was in two places at the same
time while Picard sometimes spoke
disparagingly of the stargazer a
ramshackle ship with an overworked crew
he did confess to occasionally longing
for the way things used to be there are
times when I would give almost anything
to come on the stargazer again the
second model is the captain's yacht from
the enterprise-e christened the Cousteau
the Cousteau was featured in the third
TNG movie Star Trek insurrection in
which Picard and the crew of the
enterprise stood against the Federation
to keep them from forcibly relocating a
peaceful species so that they could
plunder their planet's resources an
insurrection Picard temporarily resigns
from Starfleet disgusted by their
abandoning of the prime directive and
their dismissal of innocent lives in the
name of their own self-interest which is
exactly the same issue that ultimately
led to his permanent resignation
following the Romulan supernova there is
also a Klingon weapon and Picard's vault
in the Starfleet archives a curved blade
called a bat'leth the next generation
often featured lieutenant commander Worf
training and fighting with a bat'leth
that had been in his family for
generations it's unclear exactly where
Picard's bat'leth came from while it's
possible it's worse it could also be one
that Picard came by through his other
dealings with the Klingons Picard
notably served as arbiter of succession
at the request of the Klingon leader Kim
Peck during the next generation episodes
reunion and redemption and it's possible
his high standing with the Klingon
Empire led at some point to him
receiving his own bat'leth regardless of
where Picard's that lift came from the
weapons presence in his vault serves as
a reminder that Picard is highly
respected among the Klingons who used to
be the Federation's fiercest enemies
that theme feels significant to Star
Trek Picard which reveals that the
former officer resigned from Starfleet
over their treatment of the Romulans
who stepped into the role of primary
Trek villains after the Federation
finally made peace with the Klingons one
of the final treasured items that
jean-luc Picard has kept stored away in
his vault all these years is the banner
that the children of the enterprise made
for him to celebrate Captain Picard Day
an annual event in which the children of
the starship honor its captain through
original artwork while Picard was
reluctant to participate in Captain
Picard Day while aboard the enterprise
it would seem that he may have
appreciated it more than he let on if he
kept the banner for decades after
leaving his post we witness Picard
receiving the banner in the next
generation season 7 episode the Pegasus
which sees the crew of the enterprise
facing off against the Romulans to
recover a Starfleet ship near the
neutral zone during the course of the
episode it becomes clear that Starfleet
violated their peace treaty with the
Romulans and tried to cover it up but
Picard refuses to go along with the
deception revealing the truth to the
Romulans and siding against his
Starfleet colleagues in short this is
yet another easter egg in Picard's first
episode that calls back to a time when
our hero took a stand against the
federation possibly foreshadowing that
the one-time captain and Starfleet are
about to find themselves at odds once
more when Picard travels to the daystrom
Institute in Okinawa in order to dig
into the possibility that dodge may be a
flesh-and-blood synthetic he meets with
dr. Agnes jarate who assures him that
sentient flesh and blood synthetics are
nothing more than a forgotten pipedream
jarate then mentions that she was
recruited by dr. Bruce Maddox and that
the two of them had worked together to
create a sentient Android similar to
data
she says they'd been closed until the
synthetic van after which Maddox
disappeared if the name of the missing
scientists sounds familiar there's a
good reason for that
Bruce Maddox first appeared in the next
generation season 2 episode the measure
of a man in which he argued against data
sentient in the hopes of being able to
override his free will and study him
opposing Maddox was none other than
Captain jean-luc Picard who presented a
moving and ultimately victorious case
for data's personhood mentioning Maddox
in an episode already rife with themes
of sentient identity
will an individuality feels like a very
deliberate nod to one of the next
generations most fascinating Court
debates and hints that we haven't heard
the last of either side of this argument
when Picard is telling dodge his theory
about her origins
she tells Picard about a hybrid orchid
that her father engineered splicing to
genesis and naming the offspring after
her later Picard mentions to dr. jarate
that data always wanted a daughter both
lines together seemed to be a direct
reference to the offspring a season 3
episode of the next generation in which
data constructs an Android daughter
named Lal from his own design in the
offspring law evolves quickly surpassing
even data's abilities in a short amount
of time and revealing that she can feel
emotion but ultimately her experiences
wind up overloading her positronic brain
despite data's best efforts he is unable
to save her data then downloads lost
memories into his own neural net so in
that way she can live on through him the
offspring also sees Picard side against
the Federation once again when a
Starfleet Admiral attempts to claim Lal
for scientific research
Picard refuses to let her go dodges
journey and Picard's first episode
mirrors lols in many ways and how Picard
tried to protect her and ultimately and
how she died after only being truly
awake for a brief time check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Star Trek
Picard are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]